Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Teen Wolf did anyone else get a Back to
the Future Vibe? No really, it got crazy but
a few big things were confirmed. They also
decided to air the episode ahead of the VMAs
because they thought everyone would be sleeping
through Monday?
I feel like all the people who watched the
VMAs were already Teen Wolf fans, so it seems
a little ridiculous. Especially since they
already were confirmed for an expanded fifth
season. But whatever. Let’s talk about the
true alpha. Careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven’t seen it yet. Here
are my top 5 wtf moments. I’ll wait just
a sec...Okay, here we go.
Number 5 - Brett is Back
It was a nice callback to the events of episode
5. Remember, Brett is from Liam’s old school.
And even though Scott kinda saved his life
he still seems like he’s got a giant chip
on his shoulder. I’m still a little confused
about the Liam rage situation, but I’m assuming
that those two have buried the hatchet...in
someone’s face. Because now the deadpool
is at the level where assault teams packing
hunter gear are after them.
It also seemed like Brett and the girl, who
may or may not have been his little sister,
were part of Satomi’s pack. Or they might
become part of a new pack, because I think
all of Satomi’s old pack were killed by
the virus.
Brett was kind of like the stand in for rage
face Liam. Whenever you have a crazy episode,
tv rules dictate one of your friends has to
lose their shit. Like Reservoir Dogs, one
of the guys always has to go crazy.
Speaking of which, Number 4 - Liam is still
losing his mind
It’s really sweet to see Scott step up as
a big brother when Liam goes into puppy mode.
Like he wants to crawl under his bed and hide.
I was happy that Scott referenced all their
dead friends. Not everyone gets a happy ending.
I think Liam’s story was all about setting
up a big hero moment in the last two episodes.
He’ll figure out how he fits in Scott’s
world and start to think of the pack as his
There is no part of me that feels like any
of the good looking people this season will
die. Tyler Hoechlin, Liam, Kira, even Brett.
They’ll all be back for season 5.
The real person I think is on the hit list
is Satomi.
Which leads me to Number 3 - Satomi is an
alpha without a pack and three things that
won’t stay hidden.
I feel like her three things are foreshadowing
that she’s going to sacrifice herself to
save Scott.
Who else here feels like of all the epic things
that could happen in the finale. Peter will
get his Alpha powers back and be more of a
black hat wearing villain in season 5.
In order to get his Alpha powers back, Peter
needs to kill an alpha. Which he says is Scott.
But there are two alphas on the show right
now. And of those two, which one do you think
the show is going to keep.
I didn’t really see it clearly until Satomi
explained the sun, the moon and the truth
to Chris Argent. Instead of being this really
zen mantra. It sounded like Satomi truly believes
that her wolf nature will ultimately consume
her and she’ll start ripping everyone up
like during the flashback to Oak Creek.
There are a couple of big arcs people get
in genre stories like Teen Wolf. Hero arcs,
where people like Liam accept the call to
action to become a hero, villain arcs, where
people like Peter show their true nature and
tragic arcs, where good people are destined
to die. Like I think Satomi is.
Derek is a different story. I feel like his
tragic arc is a false positive this season.
He won’t end up dying and he’ll turn the
situation around and either get his powers
back or find a way to contribute without them.
on to Benefactor craziness, my number 2 moment
is Meredith and Peter.
Based on the way they presented it, Peter
is lying about Inceptioning Meredith to enact
the Deadpool List. Meredith always wants to
help.
I’m still trying to decide if I like this
explanation better or if I liked it better
when I thought Meredith was faking her disability
and was behind it all. I’m definitely happy
that this isn’t all some simple Meredith
Revenge plot.
I think Peter is only half lying, yes he did
use his alpha powers to ghost whisper Meredith
in the hospital. I think that was intentional.
Remember, his mind was completely intact.
He was just comatose. Like a highly lucid
dream he was able to control.
Meredith had just been taken to the hospital
so she was in a state of shock and open to
psychic attack. Wanting to help she listened
to everything peter said as if he were dictating
instructions.
The only part I think Peter wasn’t lying
about was going crazy. Under normal conditions
he’s lawful neutral. But after the fire
while he was trapped inside his own mind he
went chaotic evil. He had a dark fantasy that
he may or may not have undertaken, but the
fire and the coma pushed him over the edge.
So yes he’s responsible for everything but
had he not been almost burned to death, he
probably would have come up with a less crazy
plan that didn’t involve killing so many
people.
I think he’ll always be the villain of the
series, but part of what makes him interesting
is that he’s a neutral figure. He can jump
back and forth between good and evil. He’s
the Tom Hiddleston Loki of the series. Except
he doesn’t enjoy chaos quite as much.
He’s a villain of opportunity. So he’ll
continue to help Scott’s pack when it suits
him.
and finally my number 1 wtf moment - Peter
and Kate are going to Kill Scott
I should say try to kill. That’s not it,
did anyone else wonder if Peter somehow secretly
orchestrated the fire that killed his family
too?
I think it would be an amazing stroke of villainy
if he did. He’s definitely playing Kate
just like everyone else. But them working
together seemed like it only just started
this season. Their Kill Scott moment gave
me the vibe that they’d been working together
a lot longer though.
It was the fact Peter didn’t explain Meredith
to Kate, like she already knew.
Peter ranting about how Talia was sinking
the ship got me thinking. He wanted to take
control of the pack but needed to get rid
of her. So he contacts Kate to seduce Derek
as a teenager and then convinces Kate to set
the fire.
If it’s true they were always working together
I definitely think the fire was his idea,
not Kate’s. It would make her a lot more
sympathetic and Peter would be a much grander
villain.
Like I said though, I don’t think they’ll
be able to kill Scott, but Peter will probably
still get his power back by killing Satomi.
There are a number of other ways it can go
down. But in order to make Peter a viable
threat in season 5, he has to power up somehow.
But let me know what you’re favorite moment
was and do you think Peter will get his alpha
power back?
I know I didn’t mention it but the Yellow
Flower, does anyone else feel like this like
super wolfsbane or something. Like a wolfsbane
A-Bomb. A measure of last resort. It was being
grown in the Argent’s warehouse, so it has
to be a weapon of some kind. And the only
plant based weapon on the show right now is
Wolfsbane.
Normal Wolfsbane is purple though. Why is
the plant yellow? Lots of good things to follow
up on in the last two episodes.
Overall I gave the episode a solid B plus.
I loved the interrogation scene with Peter
and Meredith. That felt like the whole episode
and everything else was B-story. I like the
setups for all the bigger characters, Liam
will get his chance to be a hero. Derek is
learning to contribute without powers, Kate
and Peter reveal their game ending plan.
I’ve been really happy with the way they
got rid of the crazy supernatural aspects
from season 3B. I totally get why making the
story about much more human problems makes
all the characters easier to connect with.
And making Peter the one true villain again
is always going to be the most fun configuration.
As much of a bummer as it is to see Derek
lose the thing that made him special I think
it’s a smart move if he’s going to stay
on the show. Scott will always be the Alpha
despite what Peter says.
So it really narrowed a lot of places you
could take Derek’s character. Now in season
5, he has this whole new Derek he learn how
to be. It will be like a reverse Liam. Liam
learns to fit in with his new powers, Derek
learns how to fit in without his powers.
Like I said, Teen Wolf Buddy Cop Spinoff.
I just feel like that would be a cool show
for Derek, Chris Argent and Braeden. I didn’t
include Parrish, because you can’t have
parrish without Lydia and Lydia will always
stay with the pack.
Final thoughts are that I’ve very excited
about the last two episodes. It’s been a
great season, way better than 3B.
So in case you don’t follow me on twitter
or facebook, I’ve been moving this week.
I’ll do a room tour video when I’m done,
but I’ve got a bunch more videos to finish
and I’m way behind.
My next Teen wolf video will be next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get it if you’re
new to my channel. Later tonight I should
have a new Marvel video up. Donald Glover
is going to play spiderman in a cartoon. So
I’ll explain what’s going on with that.
Right now click here for last week’s Teen
Wolf and click here to learn all about Doctor
Who this season. Episode 1 just aired and
it is amazing.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!